many Americans are enjoying a long
holiday weekend taking a break from
their typical eight hour work days well
in China the government officially caps
workers days at eight hours as well or a
maximum of forty-four hours a week but a
so-called nine nine six schedule is
pressuring some workers into 12-hour
days six days a week
Elizabeth Palmer met a Beijing engineer
searching for that all-important
work-life balance these aren't your
average Peking ducks they're Austin
Liu's pets therapy you might call them
for an IT engineer whose life has been
work work work it's big yeah his day at
one of China's tech giants started at 8
a.m. and should have ended at 8:00 p.m.
and Kanban either but he says nobody
wanted to be the first to leave or you'd
be labeled unprofessional or uncommitted
way back home in China there is an
expression for this grueling work
schedule it's 996 which means 9:00 in
the morning until 9:00 in the evening
six days a week and that includes hours
and hours of unpaid overtime that's
illegal but the government turns a blind
eye because long hours like that built
China's tech giant's like the retail
powerhouse Alibaba and Huawei companies
that employ millions and make billions
now though change is in the air if
you're gonna have nine nine six work
culture I'm sorry you're not going to be
able to get the top Chinese talent
anymore Sean Rhine of the China market
research group in Shanghai says a decade
ago young people here were excited to be
part of the race to make China a world
leader in tech now the thrill and the
promise of striking it rich are largely
gone younger Chinese just don't want to
slave away working either for a
multinational company work in a factory
or even work for a Chinese billionaire
like Jack Ma and they're starting to
push back
that's not welcome news for tech bosses
like Jack Ma who actually called 996 a
huge blessing tech employees in Silicon
Valley worked long hours to of course
but they get perks that range from free
food - unlimited vacation not so in
China so four months ago
Austen you quit his 996 job to get a
life would you like to see some
leadership from the tech titans to
recognize that long hours don't equal
excellent productivity
can you see Wong yes he says they need
to recognize that productivity depends
on employees health and quality of life
Austan loo like Millennials everywhere
including in China has decided that the
key to success at work is making enough
time to play for CBS this morning
Elizabeth Palmer Beijing makes you
grateful for your weekend and our jobs
and our fine